why is understanding genres so important
genre is really the key to understanding
screenwriting today and it comes from
what I call the first Google of
Hollywood which is that Hollywood
doesn't mind some movie stars directors
or writers it buys and sells genres now
genres are story forms and more
importantly that they are the all-stars
of the story world they are story forms
that have been told over decades
centuries and in some cases like with
myth thousands of years so they've
already been worked out and they've been
worked out very very great detail and
they know exactly how their characters
work they know what their themes are
they know how the plot is going to work
and so on so it's very very tight now in
order to sell to a worldwide audience
you have to use these different genres
because this is this is what the
audience is really buying one when an
audience goes to see one of the the big
summer blockbuster films they may not
know it in their head oh that's a myth
based film or that's an action film or a
combination of the two but they know
what they like and that's what's
underneath each one of those stories
Avengers Dark Knight so on these are all
just basic story forms basic Jean Rah's
a skin placement on top so it's very
important first of all for the writer to
understand what genre is they are
working in it's also very important for
them to understand how to combine their
genres because almost every film that
gets made now is not a Singlish honor
that was decades ago now almost every
film that gets made not just in
Hollywood but in worldwide cinema is a
combination of two three and sometimes
four genres
now a lot of writers know this what they
don't know they usually don't know is
that combining genres is very difficult
because each genre has its own hero its
own opponent its own desire line theme
and so on so when you start combining
these typically you end up with chaos
you end up with so many story elements
that are unconnected that the script
doesn't work so it's very important to
understand how to put these genres
together one final point about this when
a writer is developing a story idea
right at the beginning of the writing
process they come up against the biggest
decision that they will have to make
which is what genre is this story the
biggest reason that writers fail at the
premise and by the way 99% of scripts
fail at the premise line right the very
first decision in the writing process
the biggest reason it fails is not that
it was wasn't a good idea it's that they
used the wrong genre to develop the idea
you